غير مقنع وغير متأثر من قبل خبراء الصحة
يلعب الرئيس ترامب دور
مشتت الانتباه في اختيار المعارك
ونشر المعلومات الخاطئة مثل
عدد القتلى في الولايات المتحدة.  من فيروس كورونا الذي
حلق في علامة فارقة مفجعة تتمثل
في فقدان مئات الآلاف من الأرواح مما أدى إلى تأجيج
حرب ثقافية لارتدائها الأقنعة ،
هل يمكنك تناولها لأنني لا أستطيع هنا
أن أتحدث بصوت أعلى سيدي ، حسنًا ، أنت
تريد أن تكون على حق من الناحية السياسية ، تفضل
ولكن حتى  زملاؤنا الجمهوريون لا
يتبعون خطى الرئيس ،
هذا لا يتعلق بالسياسة ، ولا يتعلق
بالليبرالية أو المحافظة ،
هذه ليست قضية محافظة ليبرالية ،
إنها قضية تتعلق بكيفية حماية
جاري ، كيف أحمي الأشخاص الذين
أحبهم  كيف يمكنني حماية الأشخاص الذين
لا أعرف حتى أن الرئيس وجه
هجمات كاذبة للحرب على MSNBC ، حيث
وجه جو سكاربورو توبيخًا من
السناتور ميت رومني الذي قام بالتغريد أعلم أن
جو سكاربورو جو صديق لي
بما فيه الكفاية بالفعل أن
Twitter لديه ما يكفي من السيد  .
شكاوى ترامب الوهمية في التصويت عبر البريد تؤدي
إلى احتيال واسع النطاق قام Twitter بإبلاغ
متابعيه للحصول على الحقائق التي
هددها الرئيس بإغلاق Twitter على
Twitter محذرًا من أننا سننظمها بشدة
أو نغلقها
قبل أن نسمح بحدوث ذلك على الإطلاق.
صوت الرئيس والسكرتيرة الصحفية للبيت الأبيض
كيلي ماكيناني
عن طريق البريد في فلوريدا ، وقال ماكناني لشبكة CNN إن
التصويت الغائب يحتوي على كلمة
غائبة لسبب يعني أنك غائب
عن الولاية القضائية غير قادر على التصويت
شخصيًا.
تخطط لتسييس
الفيروس التاجي وتوسيع نطاق البريد الجماعي
والتصويت بدون سبب وهو ما يمثل
ميلًا كبيرًا لتزوير الناخبين ، ولكن هذا
ليس هو الحال تمامًا ، حيث
تقول شعبة فلوريدا للانتخابات ، باستثناء يوم الانتخابات ، أنه
لا توجد أعذار ضرورية للتصويت عن طريق الاقتراع بالبريد.
خسر على الرئيس
الغائب ، لا بأس ، أنت مريض أنت على الطريق
كمثال يجب أن أفعله غائبًا
لأنني أصوت في فلوريدا وأنا أفعل ذلك
تم طرحه ليكون رئيسًا فيما يتعلق
بتركيز الرئيس على هيدروكسي كلوروكين لعلاج فيروس كورونا ، أعلنت فرنسا للتو عن حظر استخدام عقار kovat 19
وجدت أنها أخبرت CNN أن هيدروكسي
كلوروكين لم يتم استخدامه كعلاج
إلا إذا كان يجب حظر المشكلة ولكن
بشكل واضح  أصبحت البيانات العلمية
واضحة تمامًا الآن حول
عدم فعالية سلسلة من المشتتات التي يلهيها دي الرئيس
أثناء الوباء
في تناقض صارخ مع
رئيس مختلف جون إف كينيدي
ورسالته خلال أزمة الصواريخ
الكوبية لعدة أشهر من التضحية
والنفس.  الانضباط ينتظر الأشهر المقبلة
حيث سيختبر كل من مرضانا
وإرادتنا شهورًا حيث ستبقينا العديد من
التهديدات والإدانات على
دراية بأخطارنا ولكن
الخطر الأكبر على الإطلاق هو عدم القيام بأي شيء